as tu viens d'en parler le déclenché par
rapp et d'une alerte amber a largement
contribué au dénouement heureux de cette
histoire mais aussi l'omniprésence des
réseaux sociaux anne louise despatie
née la veille bébé victoria est devenu
le plus jeune enfant avoir fait l'objet
d'une alerte amber et québec depuis 2003
il y en a eu 10 mai la vitesse avec
laquelle le message s'est propagé sur
les réseaux sociaux a de quoi
impressionner
en l'espace de trois heures les parents
retrouvaient leur bébé enlevé à
l'hôpital auparavant on devait être un
onglet la télévision la radio les
panneaux son voeu de dinars de transport
de nos partenaires
quand même un certain délai maintenant
avec les réseaux sociaux twitter pour
rejoindre le plus grand nombre le plus
vite possible et facebook pour amener
plus de précision et surtout des photos
pina arcamone d'enfant retour a reçu un
message de la est ce qu a 20 heures 32
de la halle alerte est devenue virale et
on le voit dans d'autres dossiers de
disparition ou les enfants sont vraiment
vulnérable
les gens vont partager mais jamais avec
la rapidité coûte que nous avons vu hier
et au bout de la chaîne il ya quoi il ya
quatre adolescents qui eux aussi ont
reçu ces alertes via les réseaux sociaux
là où il s'informe on le sait et qui ont
pu réagir rapidement médias sociaux en
moins l'histoire rappelle celle de
l'hôpital de sudbury en 2007 depuis
l'enlèvement d'un bébé de cinq jours
l'hôpital ontarien disposent de caméras
et de bracelets électroniques
l'hôpital général d'ottawa a également
opté pour ces bracelets au québec le
centre universitaire de santé mcgill
l'envisagent sérieusement avec son
déménagement en 2015 dans sa nouvelle
unité des naissances renvoi des
bracelets qui va emmener
jps le sud de québec qui dispose de
bracelets électronique pour certains des
vieux patients gériatrie il songe aussi
pour les poupons le bracelet c'est
quelque chose qu'on va regarder dans le
futur le ministre de la santé demande
aux établissements de revoir et de
resserrer leurs mesures de sécurité là
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on doit faire la
chose raisonnable qui est de revoir les
protocoles et de mettre en place et de
faire les ajustements si nécessaire
depuis une quinzaine d'années les
nouveau-nés en santé et leur maman
cohabitent 24 heures sur 24
c'est devenu la norme et la plupart des
soins se donne dans la chambre à
l'exception de quelques examens
exceptionnel l'histoire de victoria va
inciter tout de même plusieurs parents à
ne plus perdre de vue leur bébé ici anne
louise despatie radio canada montréal